one time when i was a kid
go on i didn't realize rams were
dangerous rams
yeah rams are pretty [ __ ] dangerous
rams what's ram
it's a ram what's ram oh you mean like a
like a male sheep oh i no wait no that's
not around no no it's not
what what's the ram
random access memory it's like a sheep
that looks like a she looks like a sheep
but it's
the sheep with like the massive
sheep
what do we call those creatures that ram
into things i didn't know they were
dangerous
when i was a kid that's what you mean
it's called a ram yeah i bet you when
you're a kid you just
caught a sheep right i was like disney
and [ __ ] so i just thought every animal
was like kind and [ __ ]
except for like tigers and stuff that's
right but i was like we don't do that so
i thought it was uh we don't know tigers
of wales well in england you're kind of
tall that
like nothing's dangerous i mean you'd be
able to like
chill out with the sheep and like just
hang out with them when you're a kid
just kind of pet them and stuff
so i went into like this like gated off
thing that was
full of ram right like 20 of them i
started feeding them grass like in front
of them like in the cage
you just got [ __ ] no they just left me
alone but then when i was doing it i was
like i don't know why i'm telling the
story but i was like 15 ram around me i
was just feeding them grass picking it
up
and then some guy some like really
really uh english like what the hell are
you doing in that cage
and it reminded me of chris he looks
like chris a little yeah he is maybe
he was like yeah like they're kind of
like the cheeks what are you doing
a young young man what are you doing in
this cage
sorry it's just sake yeah yeah and they
apparently they they could easily have
killed me so wow
oh yeah easily they're pretty [ __ ]
dangerous how because they ram you with
their horns
yeah they're like stomp on you and like
ram i didn't think there was anything in
the [ __ ] uk that could like any
wildlife in the uk
there are people capable of people die
to cows you know
do they people yeah the cows cows can
kill you they work but they can how
what if a calver just lies on you oh
yeah
what if you're just you know like
sleeping what are you doing
trying to get some milk sometimes you
might be like
just pet soaking a cow and it will
literally just go like douche
it won't it will no it won't it will
what i should you know this is stupid
the most dangerous in the uk how many
people die from a cat
dude their bite as well will rip your
hand clean off like if you feed them
like [ __ ] off
well don't kidding me you have not seen
their mouth well don't shove your hand
into a cow's mouth be surprised you want
people to see a cow and just want to
feed it [ __ ] with that light hand
[Music]
i'm not saying that going around the
[ __ ] street in gangs [ __ ] killing
you
no they can kill you it's not impossible
anything
yeah i didn't think anything could kill
you 20 people died last year anything
can kill you
yeah anything can technically kill you
but i'm not small i'm not like having a
nap
under a cow and like hoping it does
you're more likely to die from a cow
than a plane
i'm speechless
don't [ __ ] feed a cow don't be a
[ __ ]
you might die that's why we don't freak
out